salud en directo América de Francia 24 y
mar Romero Sale está con nosotros esta
mañana de martes en el estudio Mara para
comenzar hablando de un nuevo método
para detectar algunos tipos de cáncer de
forma temprana Buenos días Raúl Hoy te
prometo que venimos solo con buenas
noticias de las que te gusta sí es una
método dentro del campo de las biopsias
líquidas que es a tomar muestras por
ejemplo de sangre y hasta ahora Buscar
ADN de células cancerígenas para saber
si la persona está desarrollando un
tumor o no No hasta ahora esto se usaba
este método este método es un poco
distinto ahora explicaremos cómo se hace
y la gran diferencia el problema que
había es que en las fases tempranas del
cáncer en las etapas 1 el método que
existía hasta ahora lo detectaba solo en
el 10% de los casos una sensibilidad muy
baja en cambio con este nuevo método en
14 tipos de cáncer distintos han
encontrado una sensibilidad del 62% y
además con una precisión de localización
de saber dónde es que se está
desarrollando el cáncer donde hay la
potencialidad un tumor del
89%, el método Todavía está en estudio
esto es una primer estudio no es
aplicable desde ya todavía Por supuesto
que no pero pues tiene un potencial muy
grande claro mar y qué hay detrás de
todo este nuevo método pues hasta ahora
como decíamos se usaba Buscar ADN de
células cancerosas en las muestras de
sangre de las personas de los pacientes
en cambio este método busca algo
distinto ojo con esta palabra
glucosaminoglucanos es un tipo de
moléculas básicamente un tipo de azúcar
de cadenas de azúcar muy largas y su
presencia tanto en la orina como en el
plasma de la sangre pueden indicar este
desarrollo de células cancerosas otra
parte importante además es que esta
prueba cuesta unos 50 dólares por prueba
que es un precio muy bajo en comparación
con las biopsias líquidas que existían
hasta ahora que buscaban ADN en la
sangre además en el estudio publicado en
la revista científica penas Los
investigadores corroboraban no sé
celebraban quede se pudiera
definitivamente decir que esta forma de
buscar
glucosaminoglucanos como estos
biomarcadores como estas banderas del
desarrollo de cáncer quedará pues
demostrado y que sobre todo también
anotaban que podría ser pues
potencialmente muy útil para las
personas que ya tienen algún tipo de
riesgo que quizás no sirve tanto como
una forma de escaneo general de la
población pero esas personas que tienen
algún tipo por ejemplo de historial
familiar podrían someterse a esta prueba
y tener esa detección tan temprana que
sabemos que es indispensable pues para
salvar las vidas o para tener un
pronóstico más favorable más favorable
mar buena información pasamos a otro
tema porque vamos a hablar de una vacuna
potencial contra el chikungunya también
una buena noticia así Yo te lo dije
desde el principio esta vez es de la
farmacéutica balneva que hace tiempo ya
que lleva desarrollando esta vacuna no
es tan nuevo Pero ha publicado nuevos
datos que van alargando prolongando poco
a poco esta Esperanza porque bueno esta
vacuna se trata de una vacuna de una
dosis el estudio se hizo en 363
participantes y sobre todo lo que se Es
que la respuesta serológicas decir la
presencia de anticuerpos la protección
del sistema inmune a los 12 meses al
cabo de un año de la administración de
esta dosis sigue siendo del 99% al menos
en estos 360 pacientes previamente en
los datos que teníamos ya de los
primeros estudios que se habían hecho ya
superando además la fase 3 es que en un
mes de la un mes de la aplicación de la
dosis era del 98%, y a 6 meses era del
96% entonces vemos que esta protección
se sigue manteniendo al cabo del tiempo
no parece haber Pues un declive pero el
objetivo de Valera además de seguir este
estudio a cinco años vista para saber
verdaderamente pues Cuánto dura la
protección de esta vacuna cuando podría
estar disponible esta vacuna mar pues la
farmacéutica ha dicho que ya presentará
Pues los datos a las autoridades
estadounidenses escuchémoslo
esperamos completar pronto la solicitud
de la licencia de la fda y cambiar
potencialmente la vida de las personas
si nuestro candidato vacunal se aprueba
tenemos la confianza de que puede ayudar
a combatir una amenaza de salud pública
creciente
esta amenaza de salud pública que
nombraba la farmacéutica balneva de qué
se trata bueno el chungunya sabemos que
es una enfermedad que sobre todo se
desarrolla en las zonas del Trópico que
se transmite por vectores del mismo
mosquito que transmite el dengue también
o el virus del zika y que no suele ser
una enfermedad que cause muchas víctimas
mortales Pero ha tenido brotes
epidemiológicos en muchas zonas del
mundo por ejemplo en el 2015-2016 en
América Latina que fueron verdaderamente
dolorosos para la población una carga de
enfermedad alta y que a veces puede
tener también consecuencias a largo
plazo por ejemplo en las articulaciones
o en la movilidad sobre todo de personas
mayores o también de niños además suele
extenderse entre poblaciones vulnerables
a raíz precisamente de esta
concentración de mosquitos que son los
vectores de la enfermedad y es una de
las enfermedades que precisamente
también por culpa de estos vectores
puede crecer por culpa del cambio
climático Al haber más calor los
mosquitos encontrarán más hábitats para
reproducirse y por lo tanto pues más
potencial para transmitir el virus mar
Muchísimas gracias como siempre por esta
información y mañana Por supuesto con
más de salud nos vemos